Esta ya vale, pues nada.
Me presento otra vez, soy Santiago Vargas,
soy asesor de admisiones en en o b S y a
ver,
déjame repasar un poquito lo que habíamos
hablado previamente porque tomé algunas
notas. ¿Las habías buscado?
Estabas buscando una maestría como esta
porque habías terminado a D que lo habías
terminado.
¿Recientemente y estás haciendo unas
prácticas? ¿No? Sí,
vale la la única experiencia que tienes
relacionado con el con con el tema
también, ya sea a D,
e o o algo relacionado con los datos. Es,
es, es,
son las son las prácticas y qué te sí, no,
no dime, dime.
No,
y aparte de las prácticas curriculares
del de la carrera, pero a mayores no,
no vale, vale, no hay problema.
¿YY por qué te ha interesado después de
estudiar Adel?
¿Por por qué el el tema de de los de los
datos, qué te qué te ha motivado? Bueno,
a mí siempre me ha gustado.
¿Cómo decirlo este tipo de de ramas de
estudio? Yo estudié, por ejemplo,
el el bachillerato de Ciencias,
entonces siempre me han me han gustado
este tipo de ramas,
pero al final luego a la hora de estudiar
la carrera,
me incliné hacia hacia de y quería un
poco mezclar esas dos áreas y por eso me
estudié a estudiar ese tipo de máster.
¿Fuiste a de que salgo como más general y
luego ya pensaste en en la maestría,
ya me derivaré en algo más concreto, no?
Sí, vale. ¿Bueno,
en principio habías habías visto algo
sobre en la web de Del máster, conoces,
has profundizado un poco o simplemente
cuando viste el anuncio lo rellenaste?
El formulario ya está.
¿Sí,
luego me me metí en la página web a ver
lo que lo que decían para informarme,
obviamente, antes de pedir información,
vale, YY Qué, qué, qué,
qué conclusiones has sacado? Bueno,
estuve, tampoco pude informarme mucho,
por eso pedí más información,
pero la verdad que lo que estuve leyendo
también sobre esta Universidad, que no,
no la conocía,
me dio muy buenas impresiones y por eso.
Es 1 de los másters en los que estaba
interesado. ¿Es una Escuela de Negocios,
EH? ¿Estamos, estamos,
tenemos como el como partner académico,
la la Universidad de Barcelona,
que sí es una Universidad Estatal que la
conocerás, supongo,
tú estudiaste en la en la Universidad de
León, supongo que eres de León, no vale?
Bueno,
nosotros tenemos como como partner
académico, me adelanto un poco,
ahora te lo hablaremos de esto,
pero bueno.
Somos una escuela de de negocios de alta
dirección, es decir, hacemos, apuntamos,
o sea las personas que o bien están
cursando maestrías con nosotros o o bien
o bien ya vienen de cargos medios y
directivos o quieren llegar a a ellos,
es decir,
en el caso de que tú tomaras la maestría,
te ibas a codear con gente, pues.
¿De de tu perfil también,
pero también con mucha,
con un nivel interesante,
fomentamos mucho el Networking y entonces
tu motivación era esta, no?
¿Ya encaminarte y tener una base muy muy
muy sólida, no, y esto es una,
la inversión la vas a hacer tú,
te te ayudará en tus me oyes? Perdón,
es que se ha cortado.
Me puedes repetir la pregunta.
¿Sí te no te decía si la inversión la vas
a hacer tú,
te ayudan tus padres algún familiar o o
sí me podrían,
me podrían ayudar mis padres? Vale,
y ellos están, ellos están informado.
Te lo pregunto porque como hacer un
perfil un poco más más junior,
muchas veces hace ocurre que hacemos la
esta esta llamada y luego los padres
quieren esa otra información y.
Entonces muchas veces incluso los invito
a que puedan asistir a a la A la llamada.
¿En este caso tu ya pasaras la
información y ya debidamente te lo te lo
trabajas, no? En todo caso, en todo caso,
si ellos necesitaran un plus de
información,
ya sabemos todos cómo son los padres que
a lo mejor quieren un poco más de un poco
más de información de la que tú le DAS.
O lo que sea, no hay problema,
podemos volver a hacer una una llamada
corta y ya con despejar duda,
duda de padres.
Una cosa son las dudas tuyas y otra es
las dudas de padres. Vale, mira,
vamos a hacer una una cosa,
vamos a te voy,
te voy a compartir pantalla.
Vamos a hablar un poco del perfil de de
de la escuela para que la conozcas.
Luego vamos a hablar de la metodología,
sí,
porque tenemos una metodología propia y
luego hablaremos concretamente de lo que
es la maestría.
Y luego del proceso de de admisión. Vale,
nosotros no tenemos matrícula,
no tenemos matrícula libre abierta,
es decir,
tenemos más solicitudes que que que
plazas.
Entonces cada candidato o candidata se
evalúa la vale un comité de admisiones.
De manera individual vale,
a ver si tengo la tengo tantas carpetas.
Ay carpetas, ventanas, ventanas abiertas,
tengo 14 ahora.
Pues sí, ya la encontraré. A ver, perdona,
Eh, no quiero.
¿O es que no la tengo abierta? Ah,
no venga, aquí lo tengo.
¿Tienes la la carrera,
la hiciste presencial mientras voy
abriéndolo te voy preguntando la carrera
la hiciste presencial y tienes alguna
experiencia estudiando online o de alguna
cosa, aunque haya sido un curso o algo?
No, no, no vale, no pasa nada.
¿Marca de móvil lo único cómo?
Durante la época del COVID lo único, Ah,
vale, sí, bueno, en mi experiencia, sí.
En la época de COVID muchas escuelas
presenciales se pasaron al online,
pero no es nuestro caso.
¿Ahora te lo estoy abierto, estoy,
no es nuestro caso porque o b s ya nació
siendo VI Desintereses aquí te tengo,
vale?
Aquí estás la ves, es la la vale perfecto.
Te voy a poner aquí al ladito de la otra
pantalla. Así te veo también. Bueno,
pues nada.
Mira o B S o b s es una Escuela de
Negocios online y nació online.
Nació en el año 2006 y ya se apostó por
este método de.
De enseñanza, cuando no había ni Facebook,
ya se ha puesto por por la enseñanza
online, como te decía antes, no,
no nos hemos, no somos presenciales,
nos hemos reconvertido como ha pasado en
en algunas, no, esto pues bueno,
como puedes ver,
aquí somos la primera Escuela de Negocios
cien por cien online, el 78,
4% de nuestros alumnos o son o después de
cursar.
¿Pasa nada, cargos directivos,
ya sean cargos medios o cargos de en
departamento? Vale,
y tenemos una metodología que es la
metodología de student.
¿On la metodología de Student on es y tú
que lo tienes un poco reciente?
No sé si has seguido esa la metodología
típica de una Universidad que es que
llega el profesor.
Da la clase magistral,
tú tomas apuntes y luego a vomitar en un
examen todo lo que has aprendido de
memoria.
No sé si es un poco la experiencia que tú
traes. Sí, totalmente, vale,
pues aquí la metodología que nosotros
tenemos es todo lo contrario,
huimos de eso.
¿Aquí la metodología es práctica,
todo práctico, vale?
Sí que es cierto que hay unas clases que
luego hablaremos y hay un un material
teórico.
Pero aquí hay sobre todo,
nos basamos en el case Studies.
El profesor expone,
propone un caso con unos datos relevantes
y los alumnos,
ya sea individualmente o un grupo,
o tenéis que resolverlo. Vale,
tenéis que resolverlo desde el punto de
vista de la asignatura,
en el módulo en el que estáis de acuerdo.
Luego también hay muchos talleres y boot
Camps.
Paralelos a las asignaturas,
luego tenemos lo que es el Business plan
o trabajo de final de Master.
Lo que pasa que el Business plan es un
caso de una empresa,
un caso que se os dan un caso propio o
una idea que tengáis. Eso sí,
lo trabajáis en Grupo y tenéis que
resolverlo. Eso sí,
cubriendo toda toda la lo que habéis dado
durante durante.
¿Ese año que dura la maestría y luego
también debates, eso qué quiere decir?
Hay 1.
¿Dentro del aula virtual hay unos foros,
hay un foro donde el profesor también
expone casos y los alumnos vais a ir
dando vuestra opinión para resolver ese
caso, cómo lo resolveríais,
cómo lo haríais?
¿Tú vas a poder dar tu opinión y los
demás alumnos van a poder opinar sobre tu
opinión y ahí va a haber como como un,
como una,
como un networking y vais a aprender
todos de todos, no?
Tú puedes aportar, por ejemplo,
la la frescura y la creatividad de de una
de una bueno de una chica joven y un
señor o o 1 persona que tiene poco una
carrera un poco más dilatada puede
aportar quizás o otro tipo de opinión.
Y entre todos os vais a a enriquecer.
De acuerdo. Entonces es como muy ágil,
todo asíncrono para que podáis.
¿Dedicarle el tiempo? No,
no tanto el tiempo.
Que que no no dedicarle tanto el tiempo,
sino dedicárselo a la hora a la que
podáis.
No tenéis que estar todos a 1 hora
obligatoriamente,
como en las universidades oficiales.
Este trabajo que llevamos haciendo en los
últimos casi 20 años, porque el año,
el año que viene cumplimos 20 años,
nos ha dado.
Algunos reconocimientos, vale,
estamos en en en varios rankings,
como una de las mejores escuelas,
pero la más destacable en este caso es el
Q es el Q es perdón,
lo diré el Q es Stars,
que es una una auditora que estudia las
escuelas y universidades y otorga una
puntuación.
Tenemos 5 estrellas en el online learning
empleabilidad.
El desarrollo académico, inclusividad,
etcétera.
También estamos en otros rankings,
como es el que hace anualmente El Mundo,
el que hace Forbes. Bueno, lo puedes.
Como lo puedes ver,
tampoco me voy a extender mucho,
pero que sepas que o o b s o b s tú.
¿Tú conoces la editorial planeta? Sí,
vale, pues la editorial planeta tiene 3.
Brazos de negocio, una es la editorial,
otra es la el audiovisual,
en el que está Antena 3,
en el que produce,
como por ejemplo la casa de Papel,
VIS a VIS.
Eso lo hace el área audiovisual de de
planeta. Y otra es planeta.
Formación y universidades,
en el que hay 22 escuelas,
entre universidades y escuelas.
Nosotros somos una, hay 22 más,
escuelas de cocina, universidades,
escuelas de diseño. En fin,
quiero decir que o b s pertenece a un
Grupo consolidado y un grupo serio,
que no es una escuela que de repente
mañana va a desaparecer. De hecho,
llevamos 20 años liderando los rankings.
¿Cómo lo llevas? Alguna pregunta, no.
¿No, verdad? Como te decía antes, vale.
la Universidad de Barcelona aprueba
nuestra formación y nuestra metodología y
es partner académico nuestro.
la Universidad de Barcelona, pues,
es una de las principales universidades a
nivel estatal.
Como supongo que sabrás tú lo que recibes
al estudiar el máster,
aquí son los dos títulos,
el título de o b S.
¿Y el título de la Universidad de
Barcelona como máster propio,
máster de formación permanente? ¿Sí,
no hay distinción,
tú puedes presentar el podrás presentar
el título de la Universidad de Barcelona,
es decir,
estuve 1 año estudiando en Barcelona y
todo El Mundo se lo debe creer, no hay,
no hay distinción, sabes eso?
Es un título de formación permanente,
un título, un Master propio.
¿Conoces la diferencia entre Master
propio y máster? Bueno, a ver.
Los másters propios.
Yo seguro que tu Universidad tiene algún
máster propio que no se imparte en en
otra,
en otra escuela o que lo controlan
completamente ellos, pero yo te cuento.
El máster propio nace de la necesidad de
tener una formación actualizada y que lo
controle directamente,
ya sea una Universidad,
aunque sea oficial.
Aunque sea oficial o una escuela,
como por ejemplo la nuestra.
Un máster que no es propio sino que es un
máster oficial.
Actualizar todo ese temario,
actualizar el temario,
puede conllevar meses, incluso años,
porque conlleva hacer una petición,
tiene que llegar al Gobierno, al Gobierno,
dar el el o KY de repente. ¿Entonces,
qué pasa con formaciones técnicas como
por ejemplo esta ya?
¿Pues que se desactualiza la información
y aparte también hay una metodología que
se tiene que enseñar,
que es un señor que llega, da el el,
la formación de ese día y tú tienes que
hacer un examen escrito, no?
Entonces un máster propio lo controla,
ya sea la escuela, lo controla,
ya sea la la Universidad.
Y lo gestiona como como quiere y,
sobre todo, como necesita.
¿Qué es lo que no puedes tener con un
máster propio? No puedes ser profesora,
por ejemplo,
si te quieres dedicar a la docencia o si
quieres trabajar en el gobierno,
o si quieres seguir estudiando o quieres
hacer una tesis.
Para eso tienes que estudiar un máster
oficial. Ahora bien,
si tú lo que quieres es un máster.
Para empleabilidad, es decir,
para trabajar directamente en en empresa.
Estás en el sitio adecuado,
que yo creo que sí, no, uy,
ahora se ve se a veces se se se soporta
un poco bueno.
La diferencia es básicamente esa.
Tienes una formación con los másters
propios, actualizada,
actualizadísima de Del día, es decir.
YY con unas metodologías mucho más
funcionales,
que no las un poco ya arcaicas de las de
las universidades tradicionales. Vale,
mira,
la formación que tenemos es una formación
de impacto.
Estos son números reales extraídos de de
de ex alumnos.
El 97,
4% de los alumnos que han cursado siguen
trabajando 1 año,
1 año después de de haber acabado los
estudios, el 75,
9% reciben nuevas ofertas de empleo,
el 83,
8 aumenta su salario tras finalizar un
programa con o b S y ese incremento es un
tiene una media de un 20,5%, es decir.
La formación que que que que tú que tú
adquieres en o b s es una formación que
va a impactar directamente en tu vida a
nivel laboral, a nivel económico,
incluso a nivel personal.
¿Tienes alguna pregunta para hasta Fíjate
que todavía no hemos hablado de Master,
Eh? Solo de la escuela. Mira,
pues seguimos.
¿Tienes alguna preguntita ahora?
No, de momento nada. Mira,
te voy a vamos a seguir hablando de la
escuela, vale, porque es lo más.
Es una de las cosas más importantes.
En o b s tenemos una cultura de de alumno
y ex alumno, es decir,
te cogemos de la mano el primer día y ya
no te la soltamos nunca,
aunque haya aunque hayan pasado 10 años
que acabaste el máster. Es decir,
si tú quieres vas a estar en contacto con
nosotros y nosotros contigo.
De manera vitalicia.
¿Y cómo lo hacemos esto? Pues,
por ejemplo,
tenemos servicios y actividades que tú
vas a poder solicitar una vez de manera
vitalicia, es decir, de por vida.
Da igual cuánto tiempo haya pasado desde
que acabaste la maestría y de manera,
o sea de manera gratuita, es decir,
no tendrás que abonar nada.
Y todo esto es por haber sido alumna.
De de o b S no es algo que luego tendrás
que pagar después y no importa en qué
momento de tu carrera estés.
Ya sé que estés en una posición junior o
que quieres pasar de junior a a senior
porque ya tienes cierta experiencia y
necesitas un empuje en tu carrera o
necesitas. 1111. Pues mira,
tenemos sesiones One to One.
Vale, esto es Executive coaching,
que para por ahora más o menos no aplica.
Pero esto sería como un un coaching que
se le hacen a los ejecutivos de alto
nivel cuando necesitan.
Sería como un psicólogo para para para
ejecutivos. ¿En tu caso, pues por ejemplo,
a lo mejor quién sabe dentro de 3 o 4
años quieres crear una empresa?
Pues tenéis un un mentor para para un
para un proyecto.
Un diagnóstico de currículum, por ejemplo.
Ahora,
cuando acabes tus prácticas y acabes de
estudiar,
pues oye a lo mejor que no tienes mucha
experiencia.
¿Pero necesitas crear un currículum para
sacarle todo el provecho a aquello que
has hecho en prácticas,
aquello que has hecho,
ya sea en en máster,
aquello que has hecho?
Pues tendrás también una sesión One to
One con un experto que te ayudará a tener
un currículum muy potente para poder
encontrar trabajo. Workshops.
Todos los que quieras de liderazgo,
de oratoria,
que son unas habilidades blandas,
que van muy bien para para un profesional,
en este caso ciclos de emprendimiento.
Todo esto también está muy relacionado
con la comunidad alumni,
de la que luego hablaremos,
la Master Master clases también que ellos
proponen mucho,
la Comunidad alumni grabadas en directo y
luego portal de empleo,
bolsa de bolsa de talentos, etcétera,
etcétera.
Repito,
todo esto es algo que tú vas a poder a a
lo que tú vas a poder acceder de manera
vitalicia.
No importa el tiempo que haya que que
haya pasado,
parece que terminaste la el máster.
También tenemos unos ciclos de
emprendimiento.
A lo mejor ahora mismo no tienes pensado
emprender porque tú ahora quieres tú.
Ahora estás pensando en estudiar,
pero que sepas que.
En o b s tenemos una incubadora en la que
aceptamos o acogemos ideas buenas.
No sería la primera vez que dos personas
o 3 que se han conocido en el Máster han
tenido una idea y han o incluso la idea
del del trabajo de final de Máster la han
querido convertir en en en un
emprendimiento, pues tenemos una fase de.
De preincubadora para acabar de concretar
esa idea y la luego para acabar de
Madurarla una una fase de de incubación
incluso 1 año.
Cada año se dan 1111 premio al mejor
emprendimiento de ese año,
que es una ayuda económica para que se
pueda emprender.
Está muy bien que lo sepas por si más
adelante Decides hacer algo.
¿Relacionado, bueno,
relacionado con lo bueno,
relacionado con nada,
con lo que tú quieras emprender,
siempre estaría bien que esté con lo que
hayas estudiado, no? Bueno,
paso porque esto es un poco más de de
información.
¿Tienes alguna duda por ahora?
¿Te parece interesante? Sí,
estoy tomando esto.
¿Apuntáis? ¿Ah, bueno, vale,
está bien tómalos tómalos yo De todos
modos esta este PDF te lo pasaré la
versión larga,
lo que pasa que es como muy larga,
yo te pasé una más recortadita pero está
muy bien, toma, tómalo, eso sí,
si ves que estás tomando demasiados
apuntes YYY te estás perdiendo algo que
yo digo, me paras Eh,
me me interesa mucho que te quede muy
claro y que y así te puedan surgir dudas,
vale?
Esto es importante porque no todas o casi
ninguna de las escuelas de negocios,
universidades ofrecen todo esto de lo que
te estoy hablando.
Entonces esto es una cosa que debes saber
y debes tener muy en cuenta porque el
máster hay muchos o b, s hay pocas,
ninguna. Mira,
nosotros estamos muy orgullosos de los
más de 45000 profesionales que
actualmente hay trabajando.
Y que son ex alumnos. De acuerdo,
esta comunidad alumni es muy, muy activa.
Fíjate en tenemos en Colombia, en Ecuador,
en México, en Costa Rica, en Argentina,
en Chile y en Perú. En en en España.
El Presidente de la Comunidad alumni es
Ricardo Muñoz. ¿Qué hacen ellos?
¿Qué hace la Comunidad alumni,
la comunidad alumni?
Tienen su propia página web.
Como puedes ver, hacen eventos anuales,
o sea no anuales cada año,
pues hacen sesiones formativas de de como
puedes ver aquí ahora workshow de
reinvención profesional para personas que
a lo mejor.
Esther,
en un momento de impás y quieran
reconducir su carrera,
una masterclass de ella para buscar
empleo.
Esta te podría interesar muchísimo.
Diagnóstico de currículum,
como te he dicho antes,
Executive Prooching bueno,
Project mentoring,
esto ya lo hemos hablado,
pero mira técnicas para negociar
eficazmente. No sé.
Gracias a la Comunidad Alumni vas a tener
un reciclaje y una formación constante a
lo largo del tiempo,
de toda de toda tu vida vas a poder.
Proponerles, oye, me interesa,
necesito esto.
Conozco a un profesional que da charlas,
que que trabaja conmigo,
podría traerlo y tú propones. Y en fin,
es como una una especie de club de fans
maravillosos que tenéis una cosa en común,
como mínimo, que es que habéis OPA,
se cortó.
Hola, hay obra, te veo, ay, te veía,
te veía,
te te aceptaba y de repente estaba,
estaba. Se quedaba así pensando,
no pasa nada. Bueno, a ver,
ahora no sé si seguirá grabando o pan.
O K ahora pues sigue grabando. Bueno,
pues sigue grabando. ¿Pues bien, perfecto,
ahora se ha cortado otra vez,
no sé si ahora ahora yo no sé si eso,
yo yo estoy conectado por cable, no, no,
yo creo que tengo buena buena señal,
pero bueno, vamos a ver si se mantiene,
no?
¿Va bien, me oyes bien? Sí, sí, vale,
perfecto, bueno,
te sigo compartiendo pantalla,
vamos a ir terminando ahora sí que no sé
por dónde nos hemos quedado,
nos hemos quedado por el alumni,
sí por el club alumni. Bueno,
pues pues esto,
que que como como alumna vas a vas a
tener el apoyo,
pues esto de Del club Alumni vas a poder
participar de manera.
¿Activa y vas a poder ir?
Pues esto reciclándote con, con, con,
con con de temas,
pues muy actuales y de los que vas a
poder seguir de alguna manera en contacto
con la con la escuela.
Pasamos directamente un poquito a a ver
el el material. ¿Viste los módulos,
viste un poco el tema? Sí, sí, sí,
puede pasarle, sí.
Vale, bueno, pues como puedes, ves,
aquí hay cuatro objetivos y la idea es
que conozcas 111 de los objetivos es que
conozcas la las herramientas de Business
Intelligence y Business Analytics,
conocer las diferencias,
sobre todo entre ellas aprenderás a
llevarlas. Aprenderás a manejarlas,
eso sí, pero no lo,
pero no hace falta que sepas mucho.
Lo que sí que tienes que aprender es.
Saber qué pedirles, vale,
porque luego ya otros profesionales se
encargan de llevar esas herramientas.
¿Luego hay una, aunque las tocarás, EH?
Hay algunos, algunas asignaturas de ellas.
Luego,
sobre todo que tengas una visión práctica,
algo que puedas pasar de un día al otro
ya ponerlo en práctica después de
estudiar el máster,
visión estratégica sobre todo y gestión
de.
De de proyectos, pues en 3 en 3 bloques,
que sería la iniciación a los datos,
profundización en el Business
Intelligence y el tercer bloque,
herramientas y toma de de decisiones.
¿Porque ya te digo que apuntamos alto, Eh?
¿Los másters de aquí son para eso,
para qué?
O bien para personas que ya están en
cargos medios o altos,
o bien y estratégicos,
o bien para personas como por ejemplo tú,
que están en ese.
¿Que tienen ese objetivo en en mente? No,
no voy a entrar mucho,
tampoco en las asignaturas porque las
puedes ver, pero bueno, aquí las tienes,
Business analytics, data mining,
esos buenos, perdón,
estos son los módulos,
cuidado que me equivoco, los módulos,
hay 10 módulos, un módulo por mes.
¿Vale, es decir,
no vas a solapar módulos y ahora qué,
qué estudio? ¿Y ahora qué me toca?
¿A quién le he dedicado más tiempo?
El día 1 hasta el día 31 de ese mes,
solo un módulo tenéis una clase semanal
de 1:30 H en directo suelen ser a las
18:00 h de la tarde o por ahí esa esa se
graba.
Si tú no puedes acudir ese día no pasa
nada, la puedes acudir, la puedes.
Ver grabada pero es una clase en directo.
Aquí no hay material grabado de hace no
sé cuántos meses y contacto directo con
los profesores. Totalmente.
Ellos te van a contestar las dudas,
ya sea que la hayas visto en directo,
la clase o ya sea que la hayas visto en
diferido,
es una de las cosas que de en la que en
las que en las que ponemos mucho,
mucho empeño.
En que las preguntas se resuelvan rápido
y en que haya mucha comunicación entre
entre los alumnos y entre los alumnos YY
los y los profesores. Sí,
déjame que voy a echar un poquito atrás
porque aquí había una cosa, data,
aquí estás.
Ese es el browser que te voy a enviar
exactamente, vale,
pero me interesaba que vieras una cosa
que solo está aquí, que lo vieras conmigo.
Vale que luego,
luego el modelo de acompañamiento,
sobre todo tenéis unos coordinadores
académicos,
se os asocia al principio un coordinador
académico,
que es la persona que os va a acompañar,
vale para acá cualquier tripa que se te
rompa. ¿Tú le dirás, Ah,
he tenido este problema?
Me he puesto mala,
llevo 10 días en cama y no he podido
hacer nada. ¿Bueno,
pues entonces ellos van a van a ayudarte,
es decir, vale,
yo le comunico al profesor Comunícale
cualquier problema que tengas no es un
profesor, Eh? No, no,
no te va a resolver una duda de un de un
de una de una asignatura es es vuestro
punto de apoyo, es la persona que va,
va a cuanto menos lo uséis.
Mejor os irá exactamente,
lo digo porque eso quiere decir que
estáis teniendo menos problema no,
pero no hay ningún tipo,
cualquier cosa que preguntéis es vuestra
ventanilla única,
es vuestra ventanilla única y veis Eh,
y esto es esto, es el esto es el timeline,
esto amarillo que veis aquí,
esto es abril,
aquí empieza el máster bloque 1,
bloque dos, bloque 3,
miles de spland como te he dicho,
10 asignaturas 10, o sea 10 asignaturas,
no 10 módulos.
10 meses,
los dos últimos meses para el trabajo de
final de de máster. Eso sí,
el trabajo de El trabajo de final de
máster lo empezáis el el mes 6.
Ya lo empezáis a pensar y lo empezáis a
trabajar para que hayáis tenido 6 meses
para conocer a los compañeros y ver qué
compañero,
con qué compañero Tenéis más afinidad o
cuál os gusta más,
con cuál vais a poder trabajar y poder
elegir de manera estratégica.
Esa línea amarilla que empieza en abril
es cuando empieza el máster.
¿La actividad premaster ha empezado ya?
¿Qué tenemos? Tenemos talleres, bootcamps,
tenemos programas de desarrollo
profesional. Todo esto ha empezado ya.
No es actividad evaluable,
pero esa actividad muy interesante de que
la puedas hacer la puedes hacer durante
el máster también o después no, pero.
¿Nosotros empezamos una actividad
premaster para ir como calentando motores,
no? Qué tenemos, pues personal branding,
data storytelling.
¿Sabes lo que es data storytelling? No,
pues te te vas a enterar,
si haces el máster Te vas a enterar.
Por eso es una modalidad que que se está
poniendo muy de moda ahora,
porque como como sabrás,
presentar datos puede ser la cosa más
aburrida del mundo, no tus datos.
Presentárselos a un comité a
presentárselos, a a a 1 despacho,
a un cliente o al entonces es como una
manera de presentar datos creando una
historia. Es como contando una historia,
voy a contar,
voy a dar los datos que hemos obtenido y
lo que vamos a poder hacer no es una cosa
que se ha puesto como muy de moda ahora y
como tú vas a trabajar datos pues lo
sabrás y te es este es un taller que vas
a poder hacer.
Ya pre pensamiento creativo,
un taller de I a generativa,
bueno veo aquí y el curso de I a de
Google. Todo esto con certificaciones.
Luego un curso de nivelación como los
alumnos todos venís un poco de de de
diferentes edades,
cada 1 viene con más experiencia,
otro recientemente han estudiado como tú,
hay otros que estudiaron hace mucho
tiempo. Hay unos unos cursos.
Nivelatorios,
que en este caso sería introducción a
Python, infraestructuras TIY,
matemáticas y estadística para que todos
tengáis como una especie de de de.
¿De de nivelación y todos tengáis el un
poco, el mismo nivel, no?
Y luego un programa de desarrollo
profesional que es con con 1,
1 docente aprenderás a fomentar pues
habilidades como la gestión del tiempo,
la productividad, la gestión del estrés,
etcétera.
Todo esto lo puedes ir haciendo desde ya,
porque empezó a principios de diciembre.
Este sería el.
¿El el itinerario,
aquí tienes los las asignaturas,
esto lo tendrás, Eh? No voy a entrar,
pero las las los módulos con las
asignaturas explicadas y aquí tienes a
los bueno herramientas power BI to blo
estas se la vais a la vais a a utilizar
to blo es la digamos, la herramienta.
De análisis estándar la vais a poder
utilizar,
tenéis las licencias para poder
utilizarlas, entre otras. Bueno, miro,
bueno, pues profundizar ya en ellas,
pero son las herramientas que ahora mismo
se están utilizando para para la gestión
de de datos en Business Intelligence.
Y luego os tenemos la la lo que se llama
la semana.
Inmersiva que se hace aquí en Barcelona y
se hace unos días antes de la graduación.
Esto se hace en junio.
En junio tenemos la graduación que se
hace en el auditorio de Barcelona.
Un acto solemne, como puedes ver aquí,
como la ocasión lo merece,
pero previamente los días de antes,
pues se hacen una visita a a 1,
visita al al Fútbol Club Barcelona,
se hace un cóctel de networking para que.
Los alumnos os conozcáis cursos de
inteligencia artificial. En fin, se hacen.
Todo esto está incluido, repito,
incluido en en lo que en la impresión del
máster.
Lo que si tienes que pagar es el
desplazamiento,
la comida y el y el alojamiento aquí en
Barcelona. Pero todo es.
Todos los actos están incluidos.
Por lo tanto, y repito otra vez,
no hay ningún gasto extra,
ni siquiera en los títulos.
Los títulos no sabes que a veces las
universidades te dicen,
no sé si a TI te lo han hecho.
Ahora tienes que pagar €200 por el título.
Aquí esto no ocurre.
Los dos títulos lo vas a recibir en casa.
YY sin ningún gasto extra.
Y luego también tendrás aquí los
profesores. ¿Vale?
Los profesores son profesores activos,
son profesionales que trabajan en su
sector y en su campo. Además son docentes.
Por lo tanto,
ellos prácticamente te van a enseñar,
te van a enseñar todo lo que te tienen
que enseñar y además su experiencia,
experiencia de ese mismo día.
¿En lo que me gusta dejar claro sobre
todo eso,
que la que que la que la formación que
recibís es tan actual como ese mismo día,
como lo que haya ocurrido ese mismo día
relacionado con lo vuestro,
si tienes alguna dudita alguna cosa,
alguna cosa como que entre profesionales
os entendéis? ¿Aquí tiene su LinkedIn,
ellos son muy activos, les puedes llamar,
les puedes escribir por LinkedIn y ellos
están encantados de de Responderte, vale?
Bueno,
esto ya te lo miras tú con más
detenimiento porque ya te he hablado
sobre ello un poquito por encima.
Lo que te voy a hablar es del proceso de
admisión, vale, como te había dicho, creo.
Tenemos más solicitudes que que plazas.
¿Entonces hay un sí se se ha cortado aquí?
Uy,
esto me interesa que lo escuches porque
es muy importante.
¿Bueno, ahora cuando vuelvas, Marina,
si vuelves, ay, no pasa nada, no, no,
no me me, yo me espero, no,
no me yo me espero, no pasa nada,
pero es muy importante porque esta parte
es muy importante, sobre todo, sí,
es muy importante,
este es el proceso de admisión,
como te decía, tenemos más solicitudes,
qué plazas?
Entonces,
hay un comité de admisiones que evalúa
cada candidato, cada candidata,
en función de su experiencia previa,
que en tu caso no es mucha,
pero sí también de sus estudios y sobre
todo, de su proyección. Es decir,
qué es lo que va quiere hacer y qué es lo
que quiere conseguir con con nuestra
formación. Vale,
con toda esa información y con todo lo
que estamos hablando ahora yo armo una
carpeta.
Y además con con otros documentos que
ahora te diré,
hago una carpeta y cuando se cuando se
crea el el Comité de Admisiones,
que lo lo van activando cada cierto
tiempo.
Yo voy con todos los candidatos y
candidatas y defiendo, pues eso,
cada cada una de las solicitudes. Vale,
nosotros estamos aquí ahora mismo en la
entrevista personal vale para seguir
adelante.
Yo necesito cierta documentación para
crear esa carpetita vale,
una es tu currículum,
no sé si lo tienes un currículum activado
o sea actualizado,
pero tu currículum de todo lo que hayas
hecho ya hace prácticas.
Las prácticas que decías que ibas a
empezar ahora también las puedes incluir
todo lo que has estudiado, etcétera.
El DNI,
obviamente fotocopia del título que me
habías dicho que lo tenías,
que te lo habían dado muy rápido.
Y 1 y 1. Carta de motivación.
Esto es muy importante.
La carta de motivación vale,
en la Carta de Motivación tienes que
poner pues un poco todo lo que hemos
hablado al principio y lo que hablamos
por teléfono que es, pues yo elegí ADE,
pero a mí siempre me ha gustado estudiar
bachillerato de de de El de que
bachillerato me has dicho que estudiaste
el de Ciencias.
Yo estudié el bachillerato de Ciencias y
siempre me han gustado los datos y
trabajarlos y yo creo que tengo mucha
proyección En este sentido y sobre todos
en en la Carta de motivación pones que te
gustaría,
que te gustaría que te que te dieran las
ayudas económicas que hay ahora. Vale,
eso es importante.
Tenemos el Comité da algunas ayudas
económicas, algunas,
algunas vacantes que crean que crean
necesarias, ya sea porque.
El perfil tiene mucha proyección,
como podría ser el tuyo y demás.
¿Entonces el Comité de Admisiones qué
hace?
Te da el acceso o no a o b S y también
concede o no las ayudas económicas.
En este caso te podría conceder las dos o
solo o solo la la admisión.
Esto ya te lo diría.
Nosotros tenemos un comité de admisiones.
El último del año es el el martes,
porque luego ya es fiesta.
Y luego ya llega. Hay gente de vacaciones,
entonces lo hemos,
lo lo han puesto el el martes,
el martes que viene.
Entonces el la evaluación,
que sería la el punto cuatro y el cuatro
y el 5, te lo dan el mismo el mismo día.
Si tú quieres seguir adelante,
pues necesitaría estos documentos entre.
Bueno, hoy a lo mejor es un poco tarde,
pero el lunes y el martes porque estamos
en la misma franja horaria.
¿Sabes qué pasa?
¿Que muchas personas están en México a 7
horas de distancia y entonces tengo que
calcular, pero bueno,
tú y yo estamos en en en tiempo,
en en en la misma hora YYY,
habría que hacer el pago de la de la de
la matrícula,
vamos a hablar de la parte económica,
ahora no, que supongo que te interesa, no?
¿Habías pensado tenías algún presupuesto?
¿Habías hablado con tus padres de algo o
no? No,
el presupuesto obviamente no es infinito,
pero pero el presupuesto está abierto. Sí,
vale, sí, el el.
El máster tiene un precio oficial de 7700.
Todo lo que hemos hablado,
ni un solo euro más vas a tener que pagar
todo lo que hemos hablado,
ya sea que sea que lo que de este periodo
académico de abril a abril,
del 2026 al 2027 o todo aquello que
podrás usar o no de manera vitalicia,
vale, y este es el precio oficial.
Ahora mismo tenemos las máximas ayudas
económicas para cerrar este año.
Esto es como los billetes de avión,
cuanto más se acerca abril.
Menos ayudas habrá o ninguna vale y en
este caso tenemos un descuento por fecha
de matrícula del 22 por 101,
5% de descuento que da o b s que lo está
dando este mes de diciembre y por cierre
de convocatoria un 10% más.
No se han dado un descuento de este tipo
nunca, sobre todo este último 10.
¿De acuerdo entonces,
de los 7700 queda un importe de €5135 el
máster? Sí hay como como €2500 menos son,
son son 20 y son 32, 37% de descuento.
Estas son las ayudas económicas que que
he visto yo más.
La las más altas que he visto hace todo
el tiempo que que llevo trabajando aquí
como asesor de admisiones.
¿Cómo lo ves un poquito mejor? Claro, sí,
no, bueno, estos, estas ayudas económicas,
las las las conceden,
están concedidas ahora las adjudican a
los perfiles del Comité de de Admisiones.
Eso sí, entonces.
¿Cómo te gustaría?
Cómo podrías hacerlo apagarlo de una sola
vez o fraccionado te iría más cómodo.
¿Podría pagarlo de una vez? Sí, sí, bueno,
se puede pagar fraccionado con nosotros
en 12 cuotas sin intereses y nada es lo
que te he dicho,
5135 / 12 de acuerdo y eso es lo que te
lo que podrías, pero bueno,
si lo puedes pagar de.
De de una vez, pues también no hay,
no hay problema.
La diferencia es simplemente que
empezarías a pagar en enero, por ejemplo,
o en abril si quieres,
y pagarlo solo en 12 o en 15 cuotas.
Vale eso si si decides echarlo seguir
para adelante,
lo que habría que hacer es un un pago.
En este caso yo había puesto el 10%.
Se puede hacer un poco más en el caso de
que puedas pagar, pero bueno, sería €513.
Que tendrías que pagar el mismo día si el
Comité admite tu tu candidatura,
o sea el mismo martes y luego ya el resto
lo lo pagas 15 días después. Cuidado,
si tú lo quieres pagar, es decir,
la reserva de matrícula la haces por el
10% 513 y luego en los próximos 15 días
pagas el resto.
¿Si en esos me espero, EPA,
estás aquí de nuevo? Sí,
no sé por qué se me corta,
voy a voy a empezar a echarte de menos.
No, no pasa nada, no pasa,
pero la tecnología es así.
Cuando voy a hablar y cuando no va,
pues dónde te has quedado. Marina,
estábamos hablando del que habría que
hacer un abono el día que bueno,
en el caso de que.
Me acepten en en el Comité de Emisiones
de admisiones el Comité de Admisiones.
Exacto, sí.
En el caso de que te de que acepta tu
candidatura, tienes que hacer el 10%.
Yo he puesto el 10%, puede ser el 15,
pero bueno, el 10% ya estaría bien.
Si lo si puedes pagar con tarjeta se
pagaría son €513 en los próximos 15 días
tendrías que abonarlo el resto del máster.
O bien en esos 15 días,
si ves que al final no puedes o has
decidido,
has cambiado de idea y quieres
fraccionarlo, pues decir OYE,
lo quiero fraccionar.
Entonces empezarías con la primera en en
en abril, es decir,
que que no hace falta que que sea ahora y
que decidas si lo vas a pagar o no,
pagas la la la inscripción y luego ya
pagarás fraccionado o entero. No, no hay,
no hay ningún tipo de de diferencia en
eso.
Vale,
yo lo que te enviaré es la información
del fraccionado,
porque pagaré el pagarlo de una sola vez,
ya ya está, entonces te la otra,
es más el 10 por 115 cuotas para saber
cuánto es.
¿Entonces te voy a enviar esa información,
pero que tú la puedes enviar entera y ya
está, Eh,
no hay problema y esto sería la yo te voy
a enviar toda esta información, Eh? Todo,
todo,
todo lo que lo que te acabo de decir,
las fechas y todo lo que.
Debería requerir para para ello cuéntame
alguna impresión tuya.
¿Tenía una duda de una cosa que has
comentado, sí sobre el TFM,
el TFM es es grupal o bueno, son parejas,
vale, el TFM es grupal? Sí,
el TFM es grupal, no es individual.
Es que la la idea de de.
La idea de nuestra metodología y la idea
de o b, s es esa.
Es que haya entre entre entre los alumnos
mucha interacción porque aprendéis mucho
los unos de los otros, 1 por experiencia,
el otro por por frescura,
el otro por por estudios actualizados.
Probablemente tú estés más actualizada
que otra persona que aunque tenga mucha
experiencia.
Lo último que estudió fue hace 15 años,
hace 15 años.
Las cosas no eran como ahora y a lo mejor
se está actualizando ahora,
pero a lo mejor pues conoces tú más de de
I a o de cualquier aspecto digital, no,
entonces queremos que os porque porque
querías hacerlo individual. No, no,
no era por eso,
porque me había llamado la atención
cuando lo dijiste.
Exacto, es que no es un trabajo al uso,
no es un trabajo y luego tú lo tendrás
que exponer,
como si tú expusieras un proyecto a 1 a 1,
cúpula directiva o o al jefe de una
empresa o al encargado. Es decir,
no es el típico trabajo de final de
máster escrito como el que a lo mejor tú
hayas podido hacer o el que hice yo en mi,
en en mis,
en mis días de estudiante que es he
estado todo,
todo relleno de citas YY bibliografía.
¿No, no, y esto?
O sea,
es que esto es desechado por completo,
esto es, está totalmente pasado de o sea,
no, no, no sirve para nada,
lo que sirve es, yo te digo,
imaginaros que tenéis esta empresa con
estos datos, con esta facturación,
con estos tiempos, con estos empleados.
Tenemos estos datos que hemos sacado en
los últimos 2 años,
tenemos estos problemas y ahora con estos
objetivos vais a resolver ese caso
concreto.
Lo mismo que que Harías si estuvieras en
en una,
en una empresa ocupando ese puesto.
¿Nada de escribir YY ya está, no?
Entonces tiene todo el sentido del mundo
que que lo hagáis en Grupo,
porque es en grupo donde tú vas.
Ese es en equipo donde tú vas a lo que tú
vas a hacer.
Cuando estés también trabajando vas a
tener personas por encima de ti o a tu
lado o por debajo.
Entonces tiene todo ese sentido de Del
mundo.
¿Decir,
es bueno que te salga esa duda
precisamente por eso, EH?
Porque y es una de las cosas que que me
gustan mucho remarcar. Y es que,
sobre todo tú,
que vienes fresquita de de la de la Uni,
no quitarte de la cabeza lo que a lo
mejor hayas hecho.
No sé la modalidad de lo que has hecho,
lo que hayas hecho en la Uni.
Aquí es todo muy práctico,
todo lo vas a trabajar.
Todo va a ser como un simulacro de la de
de la de la vida real laboral.
Esto sería, pues hacemos otra cosa.
Yo te envío toda esta información,
te envío el PDF también vale para no
alargarlo más háblalo con tus padres o
con quien tengas que hablarlo. Vale,
en el caso de que ellos quisieran
información de primera mano,
yo podría el lunes como a esta misma hora,
el martes ya el martes ya empiezo con el
Comité de admisiones,
ya tengo que preparar carpetas y demás.
Lo que necesitarías son eso,
esa documentación y luego ya el martes,
sobre todo si te dan el o k es hacer el
el pago el propio el propio martes,
pero ese día para llamadas y para
informar a en el caso de que ellos
quisieran, Eh,
y te lo digo porque me ha me ha pasado
que ha habido otras otras personas que
que querían pues sus padres querían tener
información también de primera mano.
Que si no es el caso y tú lo puedes
gestionar. ¿A mí me parece perfecto, EH?
Pero que sepas que estoy disponible el
propio lunes.
Vale cualquier cosa que te que te pueda
una duda. Por ejemplo,
yo empiezo a trabajar por yo trabajo por
la tarde,
pero si tienes alguna duda el propio
lunes, Santi, que me habías dicho que no,
pero no tengo el la fotocopia todavía o
cualquier cualquier cosa que se te rompa.
Que te rompa la cabeza y tú quieras tal,
escríbeme que que te haré,
que te hago seguimiento, vale igualmente.
Igualmente,
en caso de que no me hayas dicho nada o
lo que sea yo te hago alguna alguna
llamada, vale,
muchas gracias y si alguna duda que te
pueda salir después,
pues también una cosa y nada,
pues piénsatelo y ya está que estás ya
que estás más cerquita de ser una.
Business Intelligence Professional,
que yo creo que tienes mucho,
que tienes mucho que dar,
tienes una carrera muy larga si eres muy
joven.
A mí me encanta cuando hablo con con
personas así, tan, tan,
tan jóvenes y con tantas ganas.
Es maravilloso, la verdad. ¿Bueno,
pues estamos en contacto, vale? Sí,
muchas gracias.
Un saludo que vaya muy bien.